today I'll be talking about
managing python dependencies at scale
from Apache airflow
let me introduce myself
my name is jarek potchuk I'm the uh I'm
a commuter and PMC member of Apache
airflow
um and let me just see if we can start
the presentation uh from the uh
is the presentation life oh okay yes
here it is thank you very much
okay good
so uh
going back to the presentation thank you
very much uh my name is I'm an
independent open source contributor and
advisor uh which means that I'm not
employed by anyone I'm just contributing
open source this is a fantastic uh thing
to do I can recommend it to everyone
and
I'm also airflow committer and PMC
member and a member of Apache software
Foundation you can find me on Twitter
and GitHub
um and what I'm gonna talk about today
I'm going to talk about
um Apache airflow because this is the
project I mostly involved in and that's
my beloved open source project I work on
but I want to focus about on the
dependencies uh we are
so I'll tell a little bit about the what
Apache airflow is so that you know the
context uh I will explain what uh what
are the basics about the dependencies
that you have to think about when you
run a big project at scale such as an
airflow is and explain a little bit
about what why airflow is a little bit
different than most of the projects and
what kind of challenges it has and
allocated Solutions we applied to solve
those those challenges and at the end I
would like to summarize all the benefits
that we get from that from applying the
solutions that that I will talk about
so uh airflow
what what is our flow we are at Pilot
data Global so uh where it is all about
Python and data and dependencies
and and data and processing so you
probably know the picture from a few
years back from up to work about the
modern data stack and you know that data
processing is a quite a complex subject
and a lot of different things are
involved
uh and uh you can see that there are all
those different kinds of uh applications
components processing tools engines
whatever that you can use to process the
data and uh it's it's a lot a lot of
things to worry about and from my
experience to explain what airflow is to
anyone who doesn't know airflow airflow
is a tool is a kind of conductor so I'm
acquirist and I I've been singing in for
30 years in the choir so that's metaphor
is for me very very uh in close like
convector doesn't do anything conductor
doesn't perform any tasks when the music
is playing what the orchestra is playing
conductor just makes sure that all the
instruments and all the people who are
playing in the orchestra are playing in
sync that they are entering in the right
moment they are
doing the same music together even
though everyone does its own small thing
and basically that's what airflow is
airflow is making sure this is the
airflow is an orchestrator that makes
sure that uh all those different
components and all those different tools
can want to work together and process
your data that's basically what airflow
is it doesn't do much
it's just making it doesn't do it itself
it doesn't do anything uh it it just it
just makes sure that others are doing
their job
um and airflow what is important and why
we are talking about airflow in in pi
data Global airflow is python Century so
everything about python about airflow is
python uh like 99 of code is python or
the rest is is Javascript to display the
UI but everything else is Python and our
users are python our developers our
python our maintainers work on python so
python is very very much in the center
of everything we do the definition of
all the processing that we do or like
whenever you want to orchestrate
something you have to write python code
to describe that then this python code
generates the dependencies between the
tasks
yeah so that's that's all about airflow
I will not talk too much about airflow
as an application uh um a little bit I
will talk about that a little bit but
first few words about dependencies
you probably when you are using python
you are developing python applications
you're probably familiar with with
having a lot of dependencies like python
the the strength of uh of python uh is
all about dependencies about the
millions and millions or maybe not
Millions but thousands of libraries that
you can use uh in immediately and that's
why power python is so powerful and to
manage the those different tools and
libraries that you want to use there are
lots of different tools lots of
different ways how you can manage
dependencies you can you can see all the
different things that you have to
remember about uh dependencies and
everyone does it a little bit
differently everyone has their own
approach there are a number of tools
that can manage dependencies between
those different libraries
so at the end what you end up with
usually is some kind of a mess or some
kind of complexity I would say that you
can manage different libraries different
way you can put some different python
version different python different
python installations
uh virtual environments
everyone has its own different approach
there and the with the number of
dependencies with number of different
versions this gets complex very fast
and there are two approaches they are
generally two approaches to how to
um how to manage dependencies depending
on what you are producing what you're
building uh now I'm talking about the
perspective of someone who is preparing
an uh using an application uh so
whenever so you can you can either
install an application in your
environment or a library when you have
applications uh you can install them in
their own virtual environment and those
applications have to be installed like
they are kind of driving the virtual app
so you are installing a UI application
and everything in that virtual
environment is this application virtual
environment and there are different
dependencies different different
properties that you want from that
application for example you want to
install the application consistently
over time you want to install it today
and tomorrow or month or three months
from now and it should install at the
same in the same way doesn't matter if
other libraries that the application
users been already released or not
and the application knows which kind of
dependencies it wants to use so in most
cases the application can simply use the
uh you can simply use this uh pin
dependencies so you can tell okay I want
this dependency in this version that
dependency in this version and that
works pretty well
but then when you have a library this is
a little bit different story because the
library are usually installed by those
applications so do you install an
application and application requires
some library and this library is
installed so when you have the library
you usually get installed this
application gets installed in another
virtual environment not yours uh and
this virtual environment uh has has to
be able to install other dependencies in
different versions so we cannot pin the
dependencies you have to specify like
what are the cons what are the limits of
your application so at least
uh python open ID which is three
something but you don't specify the
exact version so you cannot pin those
dependencies usually you just specify
the uh the ranges that the dependencies
should be in
from the development setup uh this looks
a little bit different because when you
are developing such a libraries or
application you usually want to freeze
the dependencies at some point at some
at some snapshot so that you can
consistently run your tests and you can
repeat your installation and so that you
can avoid these Works work for me
syndrome where uh the uh your
co-developer or colleague developer has
different dependencies than you so you
want to as a developer you want to turn
those kind of dependencies that you have
in ranges you have to say you have to
you want to switch in some uh set of
those pinned dependencies which for you
become and this is this is the important
uh term that I'm using quite often like
a golden set of dependencies so you have
you want to say okay right now we are
testing and developing our application
with this particular golden set of
dependencies which we keep in our CI is
using the same set of dependencies the
same versions exactly the same versions
because we want to have a repeatable
process of running the tests and it
happens millions and millions or many
many many times for for airflow that
some dependency release broke our tests
and we want to avoid that we want to
make sure that whatever we are running
with is is stable
and also it has this this challenge that
you want to from time to time you want
to upgrade those dependencies so you
want to get to a different snapshot of
of those dependencies because security
because you want to get latest updates
but you want to consistently move this
snapshot together for everyone who is
developing the application
uh so those are two different things
like application and libraries from the
user's perspective look a little bit uh
differently because for applications you
want to have fixed set of of
dependencies
uh and for uh uh okay something is uh
okay and for the libraries you want to
have those ranges uh but airflow is a
little bit different because from the
operations people uh perspective when
you install airflow you want to install
an application so you have a UI you have
the web web server and the GUI and with
this web server you can actually see the
um you can you can actually see here and
run airflow but
from the developer's perspective virtual
developers perspective is a little bit
different because in airflow you develop
your dags as python code and you use the
python code as a library airflow has
more than 70 70 Pi Pi packages and each
of those packages are integrating with
different those those are called
providers each of those packages
integrates with different service like
you have like Amazon Google and like 70
other different services that you can
use each of them has different
dependencies and when you're a developer
you have to somehow manage the uh the
fact that you uh you have all those
dependencies uh installed
um okay something uh happens with the uh
with the presentation okay we are back
okay thank you very much uh so you have
those uh those those 70 packages that
you have to manage each of them has a
different set of dependencies and those
different providers as we call them they
have different completely different set
of dependents here we have to put them
together sometimes you want to install
airflow and add the Azure provider
Google provider Docker provider Alibaba
provider and you name it and all of
those providers putting together all the
dependencies uh it's a lot it's a lot of
different dependencies So eventually
what happens with airflow we have 630
right now as we speak direct and
transitive dependencies so those are the
direct dependencies of all our providers
and airflow and their dependencies and
their dependencies Etc so all this
transitive dependencies are 630 that's a
lot that's why airflow is is quite a
beast in in that perspective uh and it
grows continues to grow and we have to
manage it somehow like last year October
when I gave previous quite different
version of that talk uh it was 500 550.
so almost 100 or 80 actually uh uh
during during a year so this is only
going to get worse it's not gonna get
better so now imagine that and now from
the user's perspective
uh you can you can take a look at the uh
at How uh the how how airflow looks like
from the developers perspective for some
from someone who wants to orchestrate
all those different components they
actually write a python code so they are
the real developers python developers
who want to use some libraries to
achieve the tasks they have we have some
predefined things like the ADB soap
operator in this case this is an example
of one of our operators one of three
thousand of operators we have but you
can also write your own python code and
your own libraries and use your own
dependencies and sometimes you want to
use dependencies with airflow uses but
in a different version
and the python doesn't have a good
mechanism for that in in the environment
where everything is run you can only
have one version of Library installed
so
that poses some unique challenges from
from Apache airflow because just to just
to re recap we have uh users who are
developing or maintainers who are
developing airflow uh we have uh someone
like admin people who are installing
airflow and want to make sure it's
installed as an application that you can
use and you have DAC developers or
airflow developers who are developing
the uh the dags or the the the workflows
as a python code and each of those users
we have to look at the uh at airflow and
installation uh from different
perspective of the users who are using
them uh you have to uh you have to look
for how their different perspective
looks like in in case of dependencies so
what's what's what's up there for uh for
maintenance main Turner so what what are
the needs of uh airflow maintainer
like we are I'm one of the main airflow
maintainers so we have like 600
dependencies installing them at a given
time as a like virtual Amp Install like
usually you do it's almost impossible
especially that we have different OSS
like Malinois WSL we are right now
preparing careful to run on Windows
natively as well uh we have more than
200 more than 100 active contributors
per month so people who are actively
contributing the code to airflow in
total we have more than 2 200
contributors that's a lot of people
everyone has their own environment and
we want to avoid works for me syndrome
wherever you develop an application so
we want to this we want to have these
snapshots so we want every contributor
from those 200 2000 people uh have the
same snapshot of all the dependencies
and that's that's a challenge to get
that because uh yeah because because of
600 dependencies and those different uh
os's different different environment
moments but we also want to upgrade we
want to upgrade quickly and consistently
from security so supply chain security
is super important for uh in the recent
world and we want to make sure that
whenever somebody releases new version
we we update it so on one hand we want
to have snapshots on the other hand we
want to update as soon as possible which
is a kind of contradicting and when you
look at 600 dependencies we have it's
about 20 updates of the week 20 security
patch feature breaking changes 20
updates a week coming regularly every
single week from all those dependencies
that's a lot
so upgrading this all manually and
trying to tell people okay please
upgrade because there is a new version
it's completely out of the question uh
even the panda bot is out of the
question because if you know the bend
about it it brings you like PRS to your
software to automatically to your to
your GitHub projects where you can
update your dependencies uh whenever
they appear but we have 20 updates a
week this means 20 more PRS to review to
take a look to merge to run the tests
that's a lot
so what uh so that was the perspective
of maintainer then now the perspective
of our deployment manager so someone who
installed the airflow so they want to
take airflow and install it and now
today and in in three months and it
should work it should be
uh it should just be
um the same the same installation
whenever somebody releases new versions
of packages or other packages it
shouldn't impact the the way however is
installed installed they want to have
some scripts like Docker file or some
other like bash script whatever to
automatically install airflow in the
deployment because they probably want to
deploy it in multiple variants but they
also want to be able to upgrade and
downgrade so packages they want
specifically for their deployment like
they have their own in uh internal tools
they have other libraries they are using
and they want to make sure that they are
installed in the version they want
so that's kind of already kind of
contradicting with the with the snapshot
approach that that I told before uh then
there is uh they want also to upgrade
the application the upgrade airflow
easily so make sure when there is a new
version of airflow like we are just now
reaching to five zero somebody has 243
they want to be able to easily upgrade
to five to two to five and get all the
dependencies that airflow needs to be
upgraded to be upgraded together and
automatically and some easy way to solve
the conflict if they have conflicting
libraries
that that was the perspective of
somebody who installed airflow but there
is the third perspective
so we have to you know it's like
different people with different
expectations and they have to manage all
of them uh is the user so the user which
is like the developer basically who is
developing airflow uh workflows they
really wants to have the no pinning of
the application because they want to be
able to upgrade and Test new version of
a library so they want to be able to
upgrade it in in like whenever they want
at will and they want to build their own
libraries they want to easily add new
packages for the development so so the
approach of application where it freezes
and tells okay those are all that I need
those are the version I need will not
work so you cannot put a requirement on
airflow
please in like this these are the
versions that we want to install like
most applications do but we want to be
able to be to have an open set of
dependencies but but then connecting it
to the way like okay we want to always
install airflow consistently but the
user wants to upgrade all the
dependencies in the independently this
is contradicting and this is the problem
this is the challenge that uh that we
that make it so difficult for for
airflow to uh uh to come up with a good
solution but we have solution I'll go
I'll get to that to that
um so another another perspective uh is
the contributor perspective
I have
um 50 bills a day we have two thousand
contributors we have more than 50 CI
builds a day and we always want to use
latest dependencies for the security
purpose but we also want to give the
contributors the snapshots so that we
know which versions they will run their
tests in and the others the other
developed the other contributors have to
run in the same version so that we avoid
the works for me syndrome so like
somebody has a different dependency it
works for him or her and doesn't work
for another and it's very easy to see
the
um to get the breaking change released
by um by someone else that will break
your uh your your tests
uh this happened to us many times and
those are very different breakages like
Moto 3 release 2 2 5 15 not even feature
release it just broke our AWS test
completely they just stopped working so
we want to avoid the kind of in external
influence on our contributors because if
somebody releases new version of package
and all the contributors will suddenly
start using and start breaking the dprs
it means that all the PRS are broken and
we want to absolutely avoid this kind of
situation because then everyone
complains that things do not work for
them and they didn't change anything
which we want to avoid so all the PRS of
our default contributors they have to
use the Frozen the snapshot set of
dependencies and that also allows those
contributors to see in the CI when the
tests are running to be able to very
easily reproduce those tests locally so
they have to somehow know and somehow
get in in the local environment when
they want to reproduce it if I see
failure on CI how do I reproduce it
locally
so Solutions the the solution that we
came up with using constraints if you
don't know constraints the constraints
is a very interesting feature of pip
you can specify not the requirements so
this is not the things that you install
but this is kind of instruction for uh
for pip telling okay if you want to if
you want to install this dependency this
must be this version so this is looks
like a requirement file but it just
contains information okay if you install
this then this version has to be used
this means that airflow can have an open
set of dependencies so that it can be
easily up each dependency can be easily
upgraded and downgraded independently
but on the other hand when you install
it you have this very nice and
straightforward way of installing the uh
a specific version of dependencies we
are not using any opinionated solution
we keep
automatically keep those constraints in
check so for every version of overflow
and every version of python we
automatically keep and this is all fully
automated in our CI we generate a golden
set of dependencies and we keep them so
that whenever you install you have this
way of very easily installing airflow
using constraints
they are kept as separate orphan
branches we have some tags in git so
it's all kept in GitHub as you can see
from this URL uh and pip is very cool
for that for actually running those uh
using the constraint feature to pull the
constraint file directly from GitHub we
would keep it separate from uh branch
and we tag whenever we release the
software so this is this is this looks
like that so you have just a requirement
file that looks like requirement file
but it's automatically generated and you
can see exactly when it was
automatically generated from our CI so
our CI takes care about that
and the important thing is also like
this uh those dependencies are actually
updated automatically by our CI build so
our CI build has some Canary build like
in Maine whenever we merge a code it
just tries to upgrade all those
dependencies automatically uh run all
the tests and in the test succeed then
it will say okay this new dependencies
which got upgraded automatically they
are new set of constraints and I'm
pushing the new set of constraints they
will be used from now on but only after
all the tests pass and this this is like
kind of rebuilt that tells us okay there
is a new dependency it probably breaks
our build the tests are failing so we
don't upgrade and maintainers can take a
look at that and fix those problems and
maybe constrain the dependencies maybe
fix the problem in tests until they do
that this is not automatically upgraded
and and all the people who are doing all
the PRS they are actually using the
older set of constraints which is kind
of tested and Frozen and every everyone
is happy and oprs are broken
this is actually super cool because uh
because then it automatically upgrades
the
version as you can see this is an
example of such an alternated upgrade
that happens so at single time whenever
all the tests passed we can upgrade all
the dependents all the 600 of them which
is cool we don't have many PRS they are
all tested with our tests so we know
they are not breaking our tests this is
fantastic we can automatically upgrade
20 updates a week very very easy
and we also have a nice Docker rice I
will not go into details because we
don't have too much time I'll have a
nice uh development environment that
uses it so this means that you can
locally install the latest version of
constraints in your Docker environment
which is like snapshot of all the
dependencies uh installed very easily
refreshed and build all the tests
so if it breaks in the CI
uh then it will also uh uh that it will
also be easily reproduced reproduced
locally and uh this this development
environment actually takes care about
all the updates automatic so what is the
takeaway from that uh what the
constraints freezing that we implemented
and constraints that we implemented uh
how they work for contributors they
provide stable dependencies for PRS for
developers they contain flexible
environment for development of overflow
for deployment managers they are uh
introducing the the way of stable
installing our flow and for maintainer
and contributors they they allow for
reproducible CI errors automated upgrade
of security and some sanity in managing
the such a such a big environment
[Music]
uh I I just want to mention I think I
think you're spot on time uh we have
we're pushing uh about I think I think
we're three minutes away from ending so
I think it's a good time to get to the Q
a if if you're at that stage right now
okay so I'm almost at the Q a uh session
just one thing so if this this setup is
good for airflow this is perfect for big
installation probably not very useful
for small installations but I think
about in the future to uh making this uh
Pap and standard how all because right
now it's custom made completely but we
would like to make it a standard so if
somebody is interested and sees that
something like that would be useful I'm
asking for like reach out to me and then
I will be building a pep uh initiative
to build it and now uh this is a time
for QA if there are any